bonsoir lundi 4 janvier 2021 très
heureux de vous retrouver pour ce
premier journal de l'année sur tv 78
bienvenue dans cette édition voici les
titres depuis le 27 décembre la
vaccination contre le colis de 19 a
débuté dans les ehpad en france et dans
les yvelines et le gouvernement critiqué
pour son retard par rapport aux autres
pays a décidé d'avancer la phase 2 de la
campagne qui est concerné et que faut-il
retenir le point à suivre alors qu'un
premier centre de vaccination a ouvert
aujourd'hui dans le 78 l'agriculture
fait face depuis quelques années à des
difficultés économiques notamment raison
des épisodes récurrents de sécheresse
c'est pourquoi le secteur est
régulièrement épaulé par les
collectivités dans les yvelines 42 % du
territoire et agricoles le département a
voté récemment sa politique en la
matière à la vice présidente pauline
vinokourov est vrai notre invité et puis
cela a été confirmé ce week-end les
établissements culturels ne rouvriront
pas ce jeudi 7 janvier en raison du
contexte sanitaire est les réactions des
professionnels yvelinois dans ce journal
enfin toute cette semaine retour sur les
événements qui ont fait 2020 dans les
yvelines avant de commencer toute
l'équipe de tv 60,18 s'associent à moi
pour vous souhaiter une très bonne année
2021 pleine de réussite personnelle et
aussi professionnels et de santé c'est
plus important on l'espère avec une
épidémie on est qu'on arrivera aussi à
bout de cette épidémie de coronavirus
comme à chaque début d'année les
chiffres les derniers chiffres annuels
du recensement publiés par l'insee une
tendance qui s'observe la population des
yvelines croix a progressivement au 1er
janvier 2021 le département comptait un
million quatre cent soixante 6448
habitants soit une progression de 20
mille personnes en cinq ans dans l'ordre
vous les voyez s'afficher versailles
sartrouville saint germain en laye
mantes-la-jolie et poissy sont les cinq
villes les plus peuplées du territoire à
noter que des pics de croissance
supérieure à 5% se sont produits à
vélizy et à achères au contraire des
communes comme montigny le bretonneux
ont connu des baisses sur les cinq
dernières années moins 3,5 pour cent
pour la vie la saint-quentinoise lé 6
pin sont le quatrième département le
plus peuplé d'île de france derrière
paris la seine-saint-denis et les
hauts-de-seine
on
mais je vous le disais dans les titres
la vaccination contre le coc u19 a
débuté depuis le 27 décembre mais au
total seulement 500 personnes en france
environ ont reçu la première dose du
vaccin à pfizer et bio ntech mais le
calendrier a été accélérée par le
gouvernement sous le feu des critiques
on en parle avec célia gars tsongo
bonsoir la rédaction de tv 78 est déjà
où en est on concrètement dans les
yvelines en matière de vaccination alors
casse personnes ont pu se faire vacciner
dans les yvelines le 31 décembre donc
avait pas de mon repos située à
sartrouville
on y était d'ailleurs le reportage est à
retrouver sur notre site internet et nos
réseaux sociaux alors cet établissement
pour personnes âgées pilote de la
campagne de vaccination est le seul des
yvelines pour l'instant à avoir plus
bénéficié de ces premières vaccinations
alors sur ces 15 personnes ce sont
quatorze résidents âgés de plus de 65
ans qui se sont fait vacciner
non c'est la question que tout le monde
a en tête en ce moment qui peut se faire
avec 6 mai un nouveau calendrier vient
tout juste d'en cas d'être établi mais
il peut encore évoluer
la campagne de vaccination va se
dérouler en trois étapes la première a
déjà débuté et concernent
essentiellement les personnes âgées en
ehpad et le personnel souffrant de
maladies chroniques ou âgées de plus de
65 ans ce qui revient à plus d'un
million de personnes
avant la fin du mois de janvier alors
mais le gouvernement essuie depuis
quelques semaines là depuis quelques
jours de nombreuses critiques sur la
lenteur donc de la campagne de
vaccination
comparé aux autres pays européens comme
en allemagne où plus de 200 mille
personnes se sont déjà fait vacciner
il sera donc possible donc en france
pendant cette première phase et non la
deuxième pour les professionnels de
santé de 50 ans et plus
ou ceux qui souffrent donc de maladies
chroniques de pouvoir se faire vacciner
eux aussi mais justement pour répondre
aux sied aux critiques le gouvernement a
décidé d'avancer la seconde phase qui
pourrait commencer donc plutôt juste
après la première des six début février
oui c'est ça toutes les personnes de
plus de 65 ans et les personnes à risque
donc les cardiaques les diabétiques ou
encore les personnes obèses pourront
accéder à la vaccination
à
concerne 14 millions de personnes et la
dernière étape cdac la vaccination pour
tout le monde oui cette phase iii
devrait débuter à la fin du printemps ou
cet été en commençant d'abord par les 50
ans et 60 les 50-64 ans parmi les
professionnels essentiels au
fonctionnement du pays les français
recevront normalement des bons de
l'assurance maladie pour aller se faire
vacciner gratuitement
un dernier mot sur la vaccination retour
dans les yvelines on a appris qu'un
centre dédié venait d'ouvrir au centre
hospitalier de versailles
oui c'est le premier des yvelines mais
attention seul lé père les
professionnels de santé c'est à dire les
médecins les infirmiers personnels
hospitaliers ou libéraux pourront se
faire là si d'ailleurs retrouver un
reportage cette semaine dans vos
éditions sur tv 78 merci célia pour
toutes ces précisions et dans
l'actualité nous l'avons appris ce
week-end moins d'une semaine après la
mort de trois militaires de nouveaux
soldats français ont été tués dans le
nord-est du mali c'était ce week-end
samedi plus précisément dans une attaque
de leur véhicule à l'engin explosif
improvisé
une troisième personne a été blessée
parmi les victimes vous le voyez à
l'image le sergent yvonne yuans 33 ans
natif de trappes
elle était maman d'un petit garçon
première femme de l'armée française tués
au sahel depuis l'intervention serval en
ivan uy n'appartenait tout comme l'autre
victime le brigadier loïc risser 24 ans
au 2e régiment des hussards du haguenau
dans le bas-rhin sur son compte twitter
le maire de trappes ali rabais a rendu
hommage aux deux soldats tués
les collectivités sont au chevet de
l'agriculture le secteur en proie à des
difficultés économiques attire moins
aujourd'hui à saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération souhaite encourager
l'installation des agriculteurs et ceux
qui veulent évoluer vers le biologique
ou les circuits courts pour ce faire
elle a mis en place l'agglomération en
place depuis octobre 2019 en prêt à taux
zéro d'un montant compris entre 5 et 25
mille euros les précisions dans cette
interview express collectées par astrid
bergère les porteurs de projets peuvent
donc nous présenter toute action en lien
donc avec la transformation alimentaire
en lien avec le développement qui lire
locales devant direct d'amélioration de
la qualité en rive environnementale
d'action en faveur de la biodiversité ou
encore de développement en termes
d'agriculture biologique et d'innovation
donc c'est très vaste dans le champ de 1
du développement de l'agriculture
ils peuvent avoir donc des subventions
aux niveaux au niveau de la région par
exemple au niveau du programme leader
européen ils peuvent avoir des des prêts
au niveau de leur banque mais parfois ça
ne suffit pas pour pouvoir enclencher le
projet est donc c'est un petit plus qui
est apportée par l'agglomération
ça a été mis en place toute fin 2019
l'année 2000 a été on va dire un peu
particulière tout le monde le sait on a
quatre porteurs de projets qui sont déjà
manifestés là pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
les accompagner donc les projets sont
maintenant en étude
on va élargir le spectre à présent et
parler de la politique agricole au
niveau départemental avec mon invité
paul in vino cours lefebre bonsoir bon
ça on vous êtes vice présidente du
conseil départemental des yvelines
délégué aux ruralité le département a
voté le 11 décembre dernier sa nouvelle
politique agricole départemental qui
courent sur les années 2021 2022
une enveloppe d'un peu plus d'1 5
million d'euros
nous allons parler dans un instant déjà
si on pose le contexte actuel de
l'agriculture on le sait des aléas
climatiques qui se répète d'année en
année du gel l'hiver des sécheresses
l'été une concurrence aussi parfois
déloyale des autres pays un phénomène
d'agri bashing que l'on voit apparaître
depuis quelques mois contre les
agriculteurs et ajoutez à cela le
contexte épidémique locaux vides 19 qui
forcément à a fragilisé certaines
exploitations le contexte n'est pas très
favorable aujourd'hui pour la grèce on
vous l'avait parfaitement bien résumé
vous avez oublié les inondations
sécheresses ou inondations c'est c'est
parfois l'un ou l'autre malheureusement
alors l'épidémie de kobe dame très
inégalement impacté les exploitations
parce que nous dans nos départements
on a beaucoup d'exploitations en grandes
cultures elles n'ont pas été impactées
par le cos vide en revanche par des
mauvaises récoltes nier comme vous
l'avez rappelé à la sécheresse mais le
co villa touché des exploitations qui
était spécialisée qui fait de la
diversification de la vente directe
certaines n'ont pas pu maintenir leurs
circuits notamment celles et ceux qui
travaillaient avec la restauration
puisque la restauration a quand même pas
mal
freiné pendant pendant une période face
est pas terminé d'ailleurs et les
centres équestres ont été très très
lourdement touché des partenaires avec
qui les agriculteurs aussi ne peuvent
plus travailler au paradis d'ailleurs
des inondations on rappelle qu'il ya eu
de gros épisodes d'inondations c'était
en 2016 dans les yvelines
du coup dans ce contexte on imagine que
c'est important pour le département de
pouvoir être au chevet de l'agriculture
de pouvoir l'aider oui c'est un
si un des
des axes qui nous qui nous paraît
indispensable au département des
yvelines parce que alors d'abord
l'agriculture est un volet économique
est extrêmement important pour notre
département et plus largement pour notre
pays
ensuite il faut quand même bien garder
en tête et vous parliez d'agri bashing
tout à l'heure et ça ça rejoint un peu
cette thématique il faut bien garder en
tête que cette ruralité à laquelle nous
sommes si attachés
ses paysages on l'a vu à la sortie du
confinement un tout où les citadins qui
venaient profiter de notre campagne
cette campagne là on la doit avant tout
au travail de nos agriculteurs qui
façonnent le territoire quand il ya un
élevage qui qui s'arrête ce sont des
pâturages qui ne sont plus entretenues
et ça devient de la friche et nos
paysages sont trouve durablement changé
donc il est essentiel pour nous de
préserver ses équilibres de maintenir
sur notre territoire une agriculture
dynamique de qualité et
et d'aider nos agriculteurs pour pour
que les fermes puisse continuer à
fonctionner parce que l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment celui du
maintien de l'agriculture selon nos
territoires et j'ajouterai à toute cette
cette question territoriale la question
plus fondamentale encore de notre
alimentation et de notre indépendance
alimentaire et là encore on l'a vu au
début du confinement les populations et
nos habitants sont massivement tournés
vers des circuits courts sont retournés
chez leurs producteurs pour ceux qui
pouvaient continuer à faire de la vente
directe et et le un des enjeux
essentiels c'est notre indépendance
alimentaire à la clé plusieurs enjeux
avec un chiffre aussi important à
retenir 42 % du territoire yvelinois est
couvert par des espaces agricoles on le
sait ceci ce qui fait le charme des
yvelines c'est ce territoire à la fois
avec un pied dans le rural un pied dans
l'urbain il faut garder cette identité
ça c'est primordial c'est indispensable
43 % du territoire et je crois que si on
ajoute les forêts c'est une soixantaine
2% du territoire bien sûr il faut
maintenir ses équilibres
c'est ça qui fait tout l'intérêt toute
l'attractivité de notre territoire mais
il faut les maintenir en gardant en tête
que ce travail des agriculteurs est
indispensable au maintien au territoire
alors cette enveloppe à l'aide 1,54
million d'euros donc sur la période je
le disais 2021 2022 ont parlé ensemble
d'un des premiers vaccins qui est le
maintien l'agriculture sur le territoire
yvelinois il y aussi un deuxième
objectif c'est aussi d'améliorer de
développer la compétitivité des
exploitations agricoles est ce qu'on
peut le faire aussi en la modernisant
par exemple on sait que l'agriculture ce
n'est pas comme les comme c'était dans
les dernières années un an site une
agriculture de pointe qui utilisent
notamment des technologies comme comme
le drone pour l'ultime bien sûr enfin
comme le drone quand comme
parce qu'on parle de gris bashing de
toutes les polémiques qui peut y avoir
sur les traitements qui sont faits dans
les champs il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
les agriculteurs ont pour traiter
notamment et puis pour cultiver de façon
plus générale des des systèmes gps sur
leurs tracteurs des buses anti dérive
pour que les produits phyto partout bien
dans le sol et s'évapore le moins
possible tout est mis en oeuvre pour que
ce soit innovant pour que ce soit le le
plus le plus responsable possible
vis-à-vis l'environnement et ça nos
dispositifs départementaux aide les
agriculteurs notamment à l'acquisition
de matériel pour une agriculture la plus
innovante possible alors je précise que
le troisième axe est de soutenir les
exploitations les plus vulnérables on en
parlait de face aux épisodes climatiques
on parlait de l'inondation des
inondations du gel de la sécheresse un
dernier mot à pauline dino cours
lefebvre sur ce qui a permis jusqu'à
présent la politique agricole
départementale elle a permis notamment
de soutenir 250 projets au niveau des
yvelines une dizaine d'exploitations
haut sur les trois dernières années 250
projets absolument très divers alors ça
peut on soutient certaines exploitations
à la suite des calamités agricoles on en
est soutenu à la suite du coc vide alors
les céréaliers n'ont pas été tellement
impacté mais les horticulteurs et
pépiniéristes qui ont été très fortement
qu'on a soutenu sous de notre territoire
les centres équestres je le disais tout
à l'heure ils ont été également et
quelques exploitation diversifiée
spécialisée
donc ça on les a aidés
et ce sont des projets très divers ça
peut aller de la construction d'un
hangar de stockage à l'acquisition de
de grand frigo pour stocker de des
fruits par exemple pour un agriculteur
qui ferait de l'arboriculture à l'achat
de buses anti dérive dont je parlais
tout à l'heure de systèmes gps et très
très divers et et ça permet d'aider les
exploitants à un vestiaire pour l'heure
pour leur exploitation
merci pauline albino cours lefebvre
d'être venu parler de ce sujet en
plateau il rappelle que vous êtes là
vice président du conseil départemental
délégué aux ruralité nous parlions tout
à l'heure du collier de 19 et de la
vaccination cette information est
directement liée à cette actualité
musées cinémas ou encore théâtre vont
encore devoir patienter pour rouvrir
leurs portes gabriela talent porte
parole du gouvernement a annoncé qu'une
réouverture des lieux culturels
n'étaient pour l'heure pas envisageable
les réactions à cette annonce des
professionnels du secteur dans les
yvelines avec justin braz et après celle
du 15 décembre nouvelle désillusion pour
les acteurs du monde culturel qui espère
ouvrir le 20 janvier prochain en raison
des données sanitaires actuelles musées
cinémas ou encore théâtre vont devoir
rester fermé pour l'instant c'est ce
qu'a annoncé le porte-parole du
gouvernement le 1er janvier
on a prévu nous à partir du 20 janvier à
une série de dates parce qu'on nous a
quand même parlé du 20 janvier c'était
l'addax là la plus lointaine soi-disant
mais j'ai peur que malheureusement ce
soit une date encore de revoyure une
réouverture tant espéré qu'ils
n'arrivent pas et des dates sans arrêt
repoussé qui ne permettent pas aux
acteurs locaux de se projeter et les
attentes des déclarations claires de la
part du gouvernement
moi je préférerais qu'on me dise écouter
vous n'avez pas gelé jusqu'au 1er mars
vous pouvez pas jouer jusqu'au 1er avril
parce qu'on s'organiserait autrement
alors que là en réalité on ne peut pas
s'organiser c'est de 10 jours en huit
jours qu'on prévient les spectateurs
donc tous les dix jours ont leurs écrits
bon bah désolé mais là on va pas pouvoir
jouer donc cesser une espèce de
mauvaise organisation qui tient pas
debout
plutôt que de faire du stop and go en
permanence moi mon point de vue c'est
que je préfère qu'on se voit fermer
sinon disent voilà on arrête tout on en
finit avec l'épidémie et on démarre
comme avant les acteurs du monde
culturel eux comprennent que l'épidémie
ne permet pas d'avoir une date fixe de
reprise
ils se tiennent prêts à rouvrir leurs
portes et attendent le feu vert du
gouvernement
vous nous avez fait confiance au mois de
mai lorsque nous avons ouvert
faites nous confiance nous avons pris
les mesures nécessaires pour permettre
de travailler dans de bonnes conditions
nous sommes vraiment utile nous
souhaitons vivement pouvoir accompagner
nos concitoyens et obtenir d'eux vous
rapidement une ouverture les
établissements culturels n'ont pas
rouvert leurs portes depuis octobre
dernier la 2020 à une année sans doute
inscrire dans les livres d'histoire avec
cette crise épidémie qui s'est abattue
sur le monde toute cette semaine tv 78 2
vous propose de monter dans sa machine à
remonter le temps pour revivre les
événements qui ont fait 2020 dans les
yvelines ce soir autour de janvier à
mars avec michael et demi d'euros
l'année 2020 commencé par du sport et la
traditionnelle conférence de presse du
paris nice le 8 janvier les
organisateurs annoncent une course au
soleil dans les yvelines pour la
douzième année consécutive au mois de
mars
au programme de cette édition des
départs de plaisir et chevreuse
fonctionnement qu'on trouve nous
organisateurs des terrains de jeux et
les civils nous offre la possibilité non
de de mettre en place un terrain en ce
début d'année le vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines accueille pas
de compétition cycliste mais le salon de
l'étudiant pour la première fois
habituellement organisée à versailles
l'événement regroupe 100 exposants ce 27
janvier
objectif répondre aux interrogations des
étudiants ont fait accueillir davantage
d'exposants
et après il ya tout le côté pratique
aussi qui est pas plus
en ce mois de janvier 2009 en parle
également politique dans les yvelines et
des élections municipales et son premier
tour programmé le 15 mars approche est
différente liste se dévoile au mois de
février commence par du basket une
rencontre à l'accent américain le 6
février deux écoles versaillais sainte
geneviève et auch s'affrontent dans un
match amical digne des plus grandes
ambiances universitaire américaine dans
la salle 1600 supporters
ouais ouais c'est une match plein et là
on a on attend ça depuis deux mois on a
oublié toutes les matous on est là pour
gagner
le mode et février est également marquée
par l'organisation du salon de
l'agriculture porte de versailles un
rendez vous les politiques se pressent
chaque année pour un troisième année
consécutive les départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine font
stand commun dans la perspective de leur
éventuelle fusion
les pressions des deux départements
était présent ce lundi 24 février les
yvelines ont près de la moitié de leur
territoire
l'agriculture donc c'est non seulement
un art de vivre une qualité de vie mais
c'est aussi une dimension économique aux
consignes à la première quinzaine de
mars est rythmée par le premier tour des
élections municipales le jour j le
dimanche 15 mars les partis mouvements
politiques traditionnels ont démontré
leur force dans le département le
rassemblement de la droite et du centre
sans vainqueur de ce scrutin dans les
yvelines
statu quo en revanche pour la gauche à
cause des divisions quant aux parties la
république en marche il n'a pas réussi
son pari sur le territoire en parallèle
des élections des premiers cas de kobe
19 sont recensées sur le territoire des
yvelines et rendez vous sportifs et
culturels sont annulés ou reportés la
course paris nice est également perturbé
avant le départ de l'épreuve le dimanche
8 mars à plaisir cette équipe ont
déclaré forfait à la dernière minute et
l'ambiance est moins festive
là on n'est pas encore serein à 100% on
sait que qu'il faut vivre au jour le
jour le 10 mars on compte 47 cas
confirmés les deux premiers décès sont
enregistrés dans un ehpad à luz yens le
16 mars le président emmanuel macron
annonce le confinement du pays
une restriction des déplacements et le
report du deuxième tour des municipales
dans les magasins les rayons sont
dévalisés pendant plusieurs jours ne
rions pas ton l'a rompu hier matin et
ont commencé à vouloir tout mettre et
dès qu'on remplisse et ça partait donc
on essaye de le mettre de l'europe et
une fois par jour parce que sinon des
comptes est solide le premier
confinement commence officiellement le
17 mars dans le département les
contrôles de police sont effectués ici
sur l'artère principale de
l'agglomération avenue du centre les
rues sont quasiment désertes
ce mois de mars se termine par une
triste nouvelle le kobe 19 ans porte le
président des hauts-de-seine patrick
devedjian le 28 mars à l'âge de 75 ans
il se battait sur le plan politique pour
faire aboutir la fusion des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine
le coc u19 une actualité qui va
également rythmer le reste de l'année
dans les yvelines et une autre
disparition avant de vous laisser celle
de bernard guignedoux qui est décédé à
l'âge de 73 ans annonce du paris saint
germain vendredi dernier sur son compte
twitter figure historique de l'équipe
parisienne bernard guignedoux avait
inscrit le premier but de l'histoire du
club francilien c'était le 23 août 1970
sur coup-franc 1970 sur coup franc en d2
face à poitiers est natif de saint
germain en laye l'ancien milieu de
terrain avait évolué au stade saint
germanois avant que le club ne fusionne
avec le paris fc en 1970 pour former le
paris saint germain où il évoluera
pendant deux saisons
passé notamment par l'as monaco bernard
guignedoux a été formateur au centre de
formation du club et entraîneur adjoint
à strasbourg et valenciennes
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]